[Music]
you
Brinn Kennedy CEO of topia welcome to
Stanford into systems leadership
appreciate your coming tell us a little
bit about your company what exactly are
you doing and what's the market need
that you're addressing sure topia is a
global mobility solution that the
world's largest companies use to manage
and move all of their mobile employees
so we unify all the different aspects of
supporting employees who are mobile
around the world and by doing so we
enable a lot of the future work
strategies the companies have today what
are the issues that people who are
moving face that your company helps make
easier for them so it's important to
look at it with the two stakeholders
that we serve so there's the
organization the HR folks who use our
product finance etc and then the
individual employee themselves so for
the organization historically they've
managed global mobility and a really
fragmented and spreadsheet oriented way
typically they interact with up to 8
different systems in order to move an
employee and so data is fragmented
processes are manual and therefore they
can't leverage that data to do anything
more interesting from a future board
perspective for the individual employee
it's a real consumer problem they need
to set their expectations about new
locations where they're going to they
need to almost project manage their own
experience for them and their family and
again today that's done in a very very
fragmented way and a very logistics
oriented way rather than an engagement
way how is the rise of a more global
labor force and a more mobile labor
force impacting your business and the
need that you're seeing is demand
shooting up at an astronomical level or
what's changing yeah it's really an a
really really interesting question so
there's always been corporate relocation
there has been a five to ten percent if
a company that relocates or goes on an
expatriate assignment traditionally it's
been done very transactionally it sort
of been west to east and it's been this
idea of kind of getting a big package as
you go to a different location
well we've seen over the last five years
and actually accelerating and will
continue to over the next five to ten is
this idea that an organization is fun
mentally mobile people work remotely and
they commit to an office they do
long-distance commuting across borders
cross states cross countries they travel
in a recurring fashion they do projects
for a month in different offices teams
need to form across borders and across
locations and then they unformed form in
a different way and so what you see if
you look at the percentage of mobile
employees that is dramatically growing
but people are moving in a very
different way than that kind of five to
ten percent has historically are the
types of industries you're serving
changing you know when I used to run a
division of GE we saw people move on we
were a global company an industrial
company playing all over the world are
you seeing different types of
organizations have a need for your
services than perhaps in the past yeah
it's it's interesting we have a very
kind of cross sector business it's more
driven by stage and footprint than it is
by segment particularly so I would say
most major enterprises today so we look
guys 5,000 employees plus most of those
companies are fundamentally reinventing
what their workforce look like looks
like they're thinking about the three
trends that we see touching the
workforce they're thinking about AI how
it's replacing a lot of jobs and
therefore they're rescaling employees
and deploying them into new jobs often
in new locations they're thinking about
different demographics of the workforce
skills shortages in some locations still
skills surpluses and others and
Millennials moving people between
locations to solve that and they're
running organizations that are complex
that are global and that have business
objectives that are not demarcated by
borders and so what that means is you
have an asset of employees that need to
be moved almost as fungible sort of
chess pieces between different locations
and projects in order to enable business
objectives and to retain them and build
a career paths and so that's what topia
does where the infrastructure that
enables all the sexy stuff around the
current workforce how do you sell your
product who's the buyer and the
decision-maker inside of the
organization and I assume some of the
people who are being impacted by this
some are impacted positively and some
are impacted negatively what's that
dynamic
yeah so we sell to the HR organization
we sell to multiple different levels so
there is a department in companies
called global mobility they have been
responsible for the movement of staff
for decades often that is perceived
pretty transactionally aligned with how
the space used to be and so we partner
with them and we implement the topia
software solution to give them the
infrastructure so that in many instances
the global mobility team can become much
more strategic around global planning
and managing the global workforce but
another part of our sail is often
interacting with the head of HR or the
VP of talent or benefits and really
helping them to plan what their
three-year work force transformation
looks like and how topia can be the
infrastructure to enable that
transformation or any of those people to
ever feel threatened the fact that their
jobs are changing and maybe they don't
want it to yeah it's it's definitely a
transformational sail so there's
different levels of the organisation
that are impacted in different ways
depending on how they decide to use
topia and so the really important thing
when when doing a transformational sail
and impacting different people's roles
in different ways is to start from the
vision for the future so where do we as
an organisation in the c-suite and I say
we by you know me plus customer where do
we want to get to at a five-year period
what does that look like what does it
look like to have a truly agile
organization an agile workforce where
you can easily move talent between
locations and so getting kind of that
buy-in that that's the goal its
organizational agility and then working
backwards okay where are we today and
how do we take steps in a
transformational way to get you to
agility so we say we help you move from
mobility transactional mobility to
agility as an organization that is a
journey that by definition will change
people's jobs impact some people in
different ways but if everyone's
marching towards the same goal and then
you can from a buying and implementation
perspective chunkin' in particular ways
to get there that's where it becomes
easier to addressed and very successful
for the organization all right so it's
some respect you're at the tip of the
arrow right you're seeing how
organizations are able
what do you think's gonna be coming in
the next five to ten years that maybe
isn't part of the mainstream of what
we're reading about today yeah it's it's
interesting so we four decades right
decades and decades we as a society I've
had an idea of a linear career you know
I go into an office I have a manager I
progress on this organizational ladder
and I don't like that maybe go to
another company or maybe I can leapfrog
the organizational ladder if I go to
another company the concept of an organ
an agile organization completely
terraced at a park it's like you do not
have a set location you do not have a
set team you do not have a set perform
annual performance reviews structure and
you know you have all sorts of other
things that go into that so what we're
going to see is we're going to see a
shift to thinking about an organization
as a very different being you will have
people that work there through
employment people in the gig economy and
kind of this constant movement of
resources between different locations
that it really ultimately enables
business objectives and enables
fulfillment for that individual employee
it's really interesting to see how topia
is really helping to give organizations
the ability to shape the future of work
in a positive way for all people but
also understanding that is it a
transformational opportunity and a
transformational experience for the
people who are there and is interesting
to see how you are all working with the
organization to try to make them
successful yes Brynn thank you so much
for coming to Stanford really appreciate
it thank you
[Music]
you